is university of lille
and take it over emily
can you all hear me
do you see my screen
yes okay perfect uh
so uh thanks uh shiprun thanks for
having
me at this workshop so uh today i will
present some work we did this spring
with a bunch of
nice colleagues from india pierre menard
omar darius dominguez anders johnson who
was doing his sabbatical with us
eduardo and mikhail valko within
deepmind
so this work will be about two pure
exploration
problems in the context of reinforcement
learning
that i'll try to describe shortly
so first a quick recap so in the url
setup the common denominator is always
an agent interacting with an environment
by choosing action observing rewards and
also
transition to a next state however
the agent can have different goal in
mind
and indeed there are several performance
measures that have been considered
in the theoretical rl literature
so first you you could imagine that your
agent
is acting out there in the wild and so
you you want it to
adopt quickly the the good behavior
you're trying to
incentivizing which you can measure by
the total reward that
your agent gets while interacting with
the environment
so this is related to the notion of
regret
that we try to minimize in some parts of
the literature
another related form formalization of a
similar objective
is to try to count the number of steps
in which your
agent behave epsilon suboptimal
so this is what is done in the pac mdp
formalism which is also related to
having a lot of
reward i would say and so in this pac
mdp framework
there have been some sample complexity a
guarantee given
so in this talk we will consider the
sample complexity of different
exploration problems in mdp
in which we forget the need to maximize
reward
for example we could let our agent do as
many
mistakes that he wants but at the end of
the day he has to tell us
what he should have done what is a good
policy to adopt
in the current environment and so we
will consider two variants
of this exploration problem so so
in the first we will give the agent
the reward function that that is
important to him and he will try to
learn a good policy with respect to this
reward function
and then we will consider a more robust
exploration problem in which we ask the
agent to have a good
feeling about the environment so that
he's able to find the optimal policy
whatever reward function we give him
later
so those are a high level description of
these two pure exploration problem
that we will study in this so in what
context will we study them so what is
our model for the environment
so here i will have many people
disappointed but i will just choose the
simplest possible
mdp model that is an episodic markov
decision process
meaning that we always interact with the
environment
in each time step successive time step
where the horizon h
is known in advance and hence our mdp is
parameterized by the states and action
space that are assumed to be finite
in this talk and also by the set of
all transition probabilities so here
p h s prime s a is the probability to
end up in
s prime given that we choose action a
instead
s in step h of the episodes
so if we know all the probability we
know perfectly the dynamics of our
mdp and then the reward function
assigns the reward for choosing action a
in state
s at step h so based on this
mdp we are interested in learning good
policies so policy simply mapping from
state to to action and
the quality of the policy is
as usual measured by its value which is
accumulated sum of rewards you get from
these states applying the policy and of
course
transitioning under your transition
probabilities
[Music]
okay and so we know well from the theory
of mdp that there exists an optimal
policy whose value is larger than that
of any other policy
for any state and in any
time step so here i i like the fact that
rewards will play an important part
in this stock that is already mentioned
therefore i will
index my value by the rewards
and also the p p star r
is the optimal policy in the mdp with
transition can lp and reward r
so the transition kernel of course is
important too but he will remain
implicit at least in my in my notation
so last thing i have to mention i will
as often
also work with the q value because it's
it's convenient so it's like the value
except you start by taking a particular
action a
in state s and the last thing i need to
highlight for experts is that here i
consider the general setting
of step dependent transition
and rewards sometimes have the paper
consider rather a static
so this p and r do not depend on h i
just mentioned that in in
for people who might know the what to
expect in times of scaling in the
horizon and so if you see an extra h
it's because i'm considering the step
dependent mode
okay so this is for the the background
now
i'm ready to present these two um to
formalize mathematically these two
problems that i'm gonna study first i
need to explain you
to you what is an algorithm form so
there are different
uh data collection process that one can
consider
in error so in this talk we will
constrain the agent to use a forward
model that is to sample
trajectories episodes uh
um in a sequence of successive states
as opposed to some paper who consider
the possibility to have a generative
model that is to go
in any state see what happens in
whatever order
so in this interaction framework
the agent will always use for each
episode t
an exploration policy that i will denote
by paiti
and this exploration policy will be used
to generate
an episode that is a sequence of states
and
action where the action is taking
according taken according to the policy
and the next state is sampled according
to the unknown transition
so in this thought the agent will also
have the possibility to stop exploration
at some point
and to output a prediction and the
prediction will be the difference
between the two the two framework will
differ by the prediction that is made
but what is common is that these three
components
exploration policy uh stopping rule and
prediction
can all three be data-dependent
and yeah for simplicity i will consider
that we always start
in the same states all the episodes but
it can be easily extended to a
distribution over
over first state okay so the first um
more well-known framework is that of
best policy identification that i will
often call the bpi that can be traced
back to a paper
by a fisher in 1994 so this paper will
have importance
later in this talk so remember it
so this problem was described in this
paper in a
discounted setting but with a restart
button and in the end it was
really using a episode so it's very much
equivalent to our episodic
setting and in this setting the agent
know the reward function and you want to
learn the optimal policy
in an mdp with this reward function
so then a bp an algorithm for bpi
can have an exploration policy that
depends on the
data observed in the past episode and
also
on the reward function r the stopping
rule
will be a stopping time with respect to
the accumulated data
that can also depend on r and finally
the prediction
is a policy that also depends on the
data you have
until stopping and the reward function
are
and what we want is to build an
algorithm that is epsilon delta
probabilistic approximately correct back
in the sense that with probability
larger than one minus delta
the predicted policy has its value that
is within its silence
of the value of the optimal policy and
we want to achieve this
while having a small sample complexity
toe
that is using as few episodes of
exploration as possible
the reward free exploration framework
rfe
that we consider now is a bit more
challenging and was formalized
at icml this year by xi jin and
co-authors
the idea is that we want to be able to
learn the optimal policy for any
reward function and for this we will use
an exploration
strategy of course that cannot be
tailored to any reward in particular
so we just assume that the agent doesn't
know what reward the optimize is for
however he still uses an exploration
policy that can be
data dependent a stopping rule and then
it's a prediction will be this time a
transition kernel so an estimate
of all the transition probabilities
in this mdp the agent was interacting
with
and based on this predicted transition
kernel p
hat actually it is possible to compute
the optimal policy
in the empirical mdp with transition p
hat and with reverse function r just
using backward induction
in our tabular setting this is uh super
easy
and so we will be a bit more demanding
for an epsilon delta pack algorithm for
reward free exploration
we will ask that this time still with
probability
larger than one minus delta for any
reward function
if you take the optimal policy
associated
to a particular reward that is estimated
from
your kernel you are epsilon away at most
from the optimal policy for this
particular reward
and of course we still want to do that
with a small sample complexity small
number of exploration episodes
so a possible motivation for this
framework is that
like if you design i don't know you want
your robot to do something
you you don't know at first what's good
reward function will make it
do the something you have in mind so you
will try one reward function
try to find an optimal policy and then
if you want you realize it's not good
maybe you will change your reward
function and so
each time in this trial and error
process you would need to redo
the full exploration in order to find a
policy
in reward free exploration actually you
are you do a bit more robust exploration
to be able later on to plan for any
uh reward so this is one of the
motivation that was given
by in the xi jin paper that i think is
is very relevant and now i'm gonna
present
a very simple algorithm actually to
solve this uh
similarly challenging and reward free
exploration
probably so this algorithm will be a
model based algorithm so
thanks to qrs talk you already know
what that is so it is an algorithm that
will estimate
the model so the underlying transition
probabilities
and in the tabular setting that we
consider we will
consider the simplest possible estimate
of the transition probabilities that are
based on the number of visits
in each state action pair so this
notation is particularly important
nhtsa is the number of time
we have been in state action pair sa
in step h of the episode before
time before the test episode
and then the transition uh the estimated
transition you just count
when you were in sa how much time did
you end up in each of the different
steps okay so based on this empirical
transition
vector so p hat t the set of all this
transition
again you can define the value in the
associated
empirical mdp and the q value that i
will always denote
by a v hat and q hat respectively
and now actually a central observation
to
to have an idea to design an algorithm
for this problem
is that a sufficient condition to be a
epsilon delta pack
for reward free exploration is to be
to have an accurate estimation of the
value function
for all rewards and all policy
meaning that based on my current p hat t
if i construct the estimated value
v hat t i want it to be close
to the true value of this policy
and i want this for all policy and
already
so how do we achieve this so we use an
id that is very
well spread in model based rl so the
problem is here we have a quantity of v1
pi
that we do not have access to because it
depends on the true transition
so we will try to build upper confidence
bound
on this error so for convenience i will
uh
look at the error between the estimated
q value
and the true q value and we will build
upper confidence bonds that are fully
data dependent
meaning that can really be computed at a
given episode t
and the very nice thing is that this
upper bound will be independent on pi
and r meaning that then we can divide an
algorithm that
is greedy with respect to this upper
bound so that
somehow reduce the error as fast as
possible
and so when this upper bounds are below
epsilon number two
then we know that this sufficient
condition is satisfied and we know that
the algorithm is epsilon delta
so how do we build uh the upper bound so
again it's a
it's a very uh standard idea and so if
you
so these upper bounds that i denote by
uh
ebar are defined inductively
so here you have a relationship between
ebar step h
and ebar at step h plus one and we see
that they
feature something that we would call an
exploration bonus so a quantity that
scale in a square root of one over the
number of visits
and here we have a an extra little thing
a threshold function that
is to be sought as a login basically
so where does this come from actually
just like in
in ucl this construction rely on
considering
a confidence region for the transition
probabilities
and indeed what we can show that on this
event e
in which for every step and state
action the true unknown
transition probability is close to the
empirical
transition probability p hat t and here
you see the closeness
is precisely measured with this beta
over m
so on this event e that we will be able
to show easily
uh to make it of probability 1 minus
delta if we need
on this event for every pi and every r
we we can easily show that um
this upper bond is larger than
the air and when i say easily it's
really this
one one slide it it is just a
consequence of the bellman equation
applied to the empirical mdp
and to the true mdp and we see that when
we
are interested in the error which is a
difference of these two quantities
you see that the rewards naturally
cancel out so this is the reason why the
upper bound will not
depend on the the reward and then
rewriting a bit uh
things you when we manage to upper bound
the
error at step h by uh the l1 norm
between the two probability transitions
and the estimated ones
and on our events we know thanks to
pink's car inequality that
this will be upper bounded by the the
thing that appears
in the bounds so the square root of beta
over n
basically and then the other term here
is the error at step h plus one here
here we still have a dependency in pi
but here by taking the maximum of
all possible action you can get rid of
it and then using induction
you manage to upper bound this by the
upper bound at step h plus one
so this is a simple justification of
this um
of this formula and once that we have
our upper confidence bond
as i told you the exploration policy of
this reward free ucl algorithm
will be the greedy policy with respect
to this quantity
and the stopping rule is as
as we expect the moment where the error
in step one
is smaller than epsilon over two because
as i told you
when it means the error is smaller than
epsilon over 2
which means that the policy will be will
be correct we'll be within epsilon
of the true optimal points for any real
okay and so my prediction is my current
uh
transition carnell appear so this
algorithm actually we came up with it by
reading this paper
by by fischer who was proposing
something very similar so still in this
discounted setting and we realized so
it was aimed at an algorithm for this
other
simpler best policy identification
objective
however we realized that the algorithm
is not depending on the reward function
in any way
so that's why we thought it should be a
good candidate for this more challenging
we're at free exploration problem
so indeed we managed to control its
sample complexity for the reward free
exploration
problem so by choosing a threshold of
order
log one over delta plus s log n we can
prove that
the resulting algorithm is epsilon delta
pack and also we can given high
probability
upper bound on its sample complexity
that
has the following scaling in the mdp
parameter so it's in h4sa
divided by epsilon square log one over
delta plus
and so this upper bound we managed to
give
is uh improving the upper bound given uh
by uh by chijin so to see
the improvement if you for example if
you don't care about
data and you look at the scaling in
epsilon
this is the term uh in this bond
and we get an h4 so we improve the
dependency
in h by a power one and then we can also
note that the dependency in
delta is greatly improved
so besides the improved sample
complexity what is interesting
conceptually that the true approach
are really completely different so i
don't have time to go into
detail about xi jin's approach but they
are using they are leaning on some
regret minimizing algorithm
and so we think that rfucrl is a natural
adaptive approach to reward free
exploration
leveraging this idea of uniformly
reducing
estimation error for any uh for any
policy
and another plus is that it has a simple
sample complexity analysis
so i managed to make it in one slide but
still in the interest of time i think i
have to
skip it so if you want more detail
offline i can
i can give some but i want to go back
actually to the
initial motivation of the algorithm that
we draw inspiration from
so this algorithm by fischer was aimed
at solving the best policy
identification
problem so a natural question is
uh okay so how good is this reward free
exploration
this reward free ucl algorithm for the
initial
objective it was proposed for so
indeed the rf crl can be used for best
policy
identification all you have to change is
the prediction rule instead of
predicting a
full transition kernel as required in
rfe
we just output p hat which is the
optimal policy
in the empirical mdp associated to this
kernel and we inherit
the same sample complexity guarantees
our
rf ucra
so how good is this so to answer this
kind of question it is a common to look
at what the lower bound says
and here i am advertising a recent
results that we
we did with omar and pierre and
actually so this might be a folklore
knowledge but we give a very clean proof
of this lower bond saying that for any
epsilon delta pack algorithm for bpi
there exists an mdp
with stage dependent transition for
which the sample complexity
has this h3 scale so we see that
indeed there is room for improvement
because we have an h4
and there is also this additional s
i did not really need to uh look to show
you there are bound to
to know that there is room for
improvement because as i already
mentioned
rfucrl doesn't use the rewards so if you
are given the reward
and want an optimal policy for this
particular reward
you should design an algorithm that
leverages the reward and
actually there are already some
algorithm out there in the literature
typically algorithms that leverage
some regret minimizing algorithm
so i present here a conversion from
regret minimization
to best policy identification that was
proposed
in the optimistic queue learning paper
of
xi jin and author in 2018
so if we take the ucbvi algorithm
of azaret al that attains a minimax
optimal regret so we know if we have an
algorithm that have this type of bond on
the accumulated regret it means that
because the regret is small the policies
not all the policy used by the algorithm
can be bad so there must exist one
policy at some point that was good
and so the idea of this conversion is to
choose in advance
some deterministic stopping time
while calibrating depending on this
regret bond that we have
and then just output as a prediction
rule one
of the previously used policy chosen
uniformly atron
and so we can prove that this algorithm
is indeed
epsilon delta pack and what is cool is
that it has
this optimal here we have an h cube so
it has the optimal
scaling uh prescribed by the lower bond
except if you look at the dependency in
in delta
here you have a one over delta square
instead of a log one over delta which is
pretty bad
so we can come up with a smarter
conversion that
would get you for example log one over
delta square but
i didn't succeed in making this static
conversion
scale to log one over delta so
i will just present you what we propose
to do instead
so as before we propose to be more
adaptive
meaning we still can't rely on a regret
minimizing algorithm
but we will assign to a regret
minimizing algorithm
a data dependent stopping rule that
would tell us okay now i can stop
and this is my my optimal policy
and not choose a policy at random in the
past
so we do that with a variant of a ucl
algorithm
that builds some upper and lower
confidence bound on the q values
of the optimal value and optimal q value
the exploration policy of this ucl
algorithm
is to be greedy with respect to the
upper confidence bound
on the q value and then the stopping
rule that we've proposed is to stop
when the size of the confidence interval
of the value
in step one is smaller than epsilon and
with this tapping rule you can show that
if you predict
the greedy policy with respect to the
lower confidence bond
then you are indeed epsilon delta pi
so we managed to uh and here yeah just
note that here the algorithm depends on
r everywhere because to build the
confidence intervals on the value you
will use
the knowledge of this particular reward
that you have in mind
so what we proved for bpi and ucl is
actually
basically the same thing as rf2 crl
because the nice thing is that
the two proofs are very similar however
it means that we cannot
show any improvement for this algorithm
from the theoretical bond
and this is why we run a few experiments
to see if indeed using the reward can be
a bit smarter
than doing this reward free uh ucl
and the answer is indeed it can help so
we measure
here the empirical sample complexity for
different
values of epsilon obtained on this toy
problem like a double chain
mdp and we see that there is really an
order of magnitude
different here the y-axis have the same
scale between
rfe and bpi user so indeed
the algorithm is better in practice even
if the theory failed
to uh to prove it so far okay so to
to summarize so the purpose of this talk
was to investigate
the sample complexity of these two
related problems of
best policy identification and reward
free
exploration so for best policy
identification
so far our current approach are not
exactly
attaining the uh the lower bond because
of an extra factor h
and an extra factor s and for reward
free exploration
actually as pointed out in xi jin's work
the factor s
has to be there they give a lower bond
in the smaller epsilon
setting however there is
also this little room for improvement in
h and so uh
i'm just mentioning here a
follow-up work in which we managed to
shave off this
extra h factor by using some more
sophisticated uh
bernstein bernstein stuff but i chose
not to present this because algorithms
are a bit
harder to to describe so you can you can
look at this
this nice print
and especially it's really non-trivial
to apply
this hazard techniques for reward free
setting because they rely on
working with empirical variants of
values
and values depend on reward so when you
do not know what the reward
is it's uh some more work has to be done
so if you are curious about this and
your geeky about you know shooting
exactly the lower bond you can
you can have a look at this this nice
work
uh what i also want to point out as
future work is that
when you see this real gap between rfe
and bpi
uh you you can wonder whether
we are looking at the right thing for
bpa because here i presented worst case
bombs
but i think it's natural to try to go
for
problem dependence guarantees for best
policy identification and i don't know
what they look like when you do a bpi
based on
on trajectories so yeah that's it
i conclude with a few references
thank you emily uh
can can you guys hear me
so i like to ask
mindy now to to join to share her screen
you